It's clear that evolution, genetics, and epigenetics come together to make us
who we are, and this is truly an amazing process. We could devote an entire
course to this, but we just don't have the time in Introduction to Psychology.
&gt;&gt; If you've enjoyed the topics we've covered so far in genetics for this course,
you should check out our other course, Tales from the Genome. Where we'll delve
deeper into the topics of genetics and learn a lot more about DNA, identity,
and health.
&gt;&gt; Thank you so much for your help on this, Matt. But now, it's time for us to
move on to something that's equally as astonishing and that's our brain. It's
truly amazing how our brain works and how complex of a system it is. So, we're
going to devote some time looking at the different functions and structures of
the brain because they're going to come up in future lessons.